would you rather let your wife [ __ ] you  once with a strap-on or take her last  name when you get married oh my goodness  well this is like either way i win this  is like two good ones i don't care about  my last name to be quite honest with you  i really don't care i take if it was a  prominent woman too could you imagine  you're like i'm mister so-and-so i'm not  beholden to my last name i'm not macho  enough like that like i'm also i don't  think i'm ever gonna have children to  pass along my name in here i'm gonna be  a step dad to begin with so i might as  well take their last name you know what  i mean and then to get to my wife to  [ __ ] me with a strap-on once like i  think if my wife and i are open-minded  we might just try that  that just sounds like